this is a production of Cornell
University
so thank you all for being here today so
as you can see about a title I'll be
focusing on my work of tracing nitrate
transformations for soil so a little bit
of background as to how I got started on
this project one of my advisors 50 video
third a nitrogen tracing experiment
about ten years ago in our net forest
and they found some interesting results
and upon further discussions we decided
that doing a lab project kind of jump
off from this work would be a pretty
interesting Avenue to go so why this is
of interest temperate forests nitrogen
sensitive largely because they have been
traditionally very nitrogen limited and
with the amount of human activity
increasing reactive nitrogen going into
nitrogen pool including their been kind
of a wide range some of which has been
speculated to possibly be positive in
terms of increased growth from
fertilization effect that might help
offset co2 emissions but a lot of the
effects that have been observed have
been more on the negative side or like
equator quality from education algal
blooms from again this increased
availability Rhian as well as soil
acidification do deposition in the form
of nitric acid and and there have also
been a lot of observed decreases in
biodiversity from changes in plant
dynamics and competitions
so to give you a broader perspective of
some of these flexes and pools now you
can see the the pre-image emic sources
fighting fixation bacterial fixation
which is how ecosystems can really got
their nitrogen but for greater inputs of
human activities and these were all this
nitrogen was pretty tightly cycled with
inorganic matter up Takens implants and
then mineralization kind of more in the
transitory forms before or lost through
microbial respiration so with amphipod
Renick activities we also get reactive
nitrogen in the form of fossil fuel
emmissions
in the form of fertilizer inputs so some
of the numbers here you can see
atmospheric deposition you can have wet
deposition or dry deposition as mone 'm
or nitrate or particles and we did have
some at the early stages of industrial
revolution but it's really increased a
lot since then you can see like the
getting kind of pre anthropogenic
natural fixation has more or less remain
the same slight decreases probably due
to decreased need from these other
inputs agricultural crop you know a much
smaller portion but still noticeable and
here you can see like with industrial
production from fertilizer and fossil
fuel emmissions we've more or less
doubled the amount of recognition
so again to kind of tie it back have
pretty some pretty significant really
interested in what happens to this
nitrogen once it so you get so I'll be
focusing on wet nitrate deposition and
here you can see some of other fluxes
that take place once it goes in into the
soils so we can get direct plan update
from ammonium nitrate or Union as amino
acids you can get a lot of microbial
biomass processing you know they can
convert between these different
inorganic forms as well as removing
nitrogen losses or incorporation into
soil solids so kind of trying to give
you a really brief background or redox
Theory what it is as I mentioned
microbes can respired this nitrogen in
the soil and the reason they would do
that is under us primarily under oxygen
limiting conditions so normally they use
oxygen as the terminal electron acceptor
for respiration activities but when so
if they have water inundating missions
or even anaerobic microsites
both start they need to turn to other
electron acceptors and nitrate is one of
their preferred ones
so further up the ladder equals more
energy gained from using as electron
acceptor so you can see nitrate is that
is close to my oxygen as you can get for
the compounds commonly you can see
manganese is also fairly perhaps air and
ein and those are also two elements of
interest you can see so going back to
that mention anaerobic microsites or
water when your soils are pretty dry you
have pretty toxic conditions plenty of
oxygen or the for microbes to use for
their respiration and they're mildly
waterlogged conditions or only recently
waterlogged
you get a slight slight oxygen loss but
not really severe yet by the time he
gets the really very oxygen depleted
conditions you can mostly have your
nitrate is mostly completely gone so
that'll be important later on for some
of the reasoning there just kind of
brings together the last two slides a
little bit my diagram some of the
processes that take place with nitrate
and some of its dominant pathways or you
can get direct uptake into microbial
biomass under ox conditions microbial
biomass also breaks down organic matter
and releases nitrate or ammonium and
they can also uptake ammonium and reduce
it or oxidize it's a night raid
and undersell suboxone conditions
nitrite is the first intermediary and
it's actually pretty reactive it doesn't
stick around very long
but that's partially that's because it
is so reactive so it can actually react
abiotic ly with different compounds in
the environment such as soil organic
matter and it's also often reduced
further so kind of bringing this back to
the reasoning for starting this project
so some of the things we know so
previous studies of nitrogen processing
in soils have looked at the fates and
fluxes fates and processes on different
timescales we have stuff that's taking
place from minutes days or weeks and
studies that typically focus around you
know what is the fate of it after 1-2
years after the initial application but
they typically don't really pair it well
with investigating the role of the
different soil horizons as well as
monitoring some of these other redox
active species like iron and manganese
so we kind of wanted to try to get at
that a little bit so moving moving back
to Christy study as far as the
interesting results that got me
questioning thank you further they did a
seasonal nitrate application with
nitrogen 15 tracer so they applied this
nitrogen 15 nitrate and spring spring
summer and fall
and got some somewhat unexpected results
particularly for the spring application
so they actually have pretty high soil
saturation in the spring with pretty low
microbial respiration which is often
considered to be one of the dominant
thanks for make nitrogen added into soil
system so since they didn't have they
didn't appear to have much microbial
activity they would have expected it
more of it to go through kind of
unaffected and into stream water as
nitrate or possibly to get respired they
actually had really good retention and
speculated that perhaps this was due to
some of those other abiotic factors such
as activity of other factors like in a
couple of soil organic matter and then
in the summer they had pretty quite
little nitrogen retention which one of
the other sinks that is presumed to be
dominant predominant is plant uptake and
so you expect lower plant uptake in the
spring before lights out and higher
uptake in the summer when they're at
peak growth and they really didn't see
much change from that
yeah so get more questions that's
exactly what is going on these soils
that's why men why and when nitrogen is
retained so from this I had two main
questions
one had a readout status thanks to eight
of nitrogen
in a forest soil and how is the
partitioning horizon so what effect does
mineral mineralogy and so to do this we
want to be able to do this we wanted to
follow partitioning of nitrates between
so that we could explore the impact of
redox status fade of nitrate nitrogen
so for the redox condition hypotheses we
believe that we will rehab osseous that
we would have greater all-over system
greater overall system losses under sub
oxic conditions just because we expect
that microbial activity will definitely
losses and under Aqsa conditions we
expect that higher organic matter
translates to more microbial processing
and more nitrogen partitioning and
conversely sub bucks it conditions will
have with low organic matter which will
have presumably less microbial
processing as well will retain more
nitrogen and we think we thought that
all horizons will have incorporation to
my car with biomass and some and some
stabilization and the lorig and matter
soils will retain more of the nitrogen
unprocessed so for our experimental site
as I mentioned these are soils from
Arnett forest nearby a little bit
southwestern here we collect these these
soils from near the top of a hill slope
so they're pretty well drained and
they're also fairly shallow really we
were only able to dig down to around 60
centimeters before hitting rocks that we
couldn't go through and these hard woods
have been
been established - since early 1900s
sense of some major fires and thanks to
hundred 1912 so we have you can see here
we have a pretty pretty well-developed
organic phrasing which isn't true for
all the soils in this area a lot of them
have had a lot of earthworm activity
where they really there's not
necessarily much from the organic rice
in the parent so we were kind of lucky
and our my choice here
is also quite ascetic so it ranges from
three and a half to pH they're all salty
salty loans or silty clay lumps you can
see again like it's pretty apparent
there that there's a lot of carbon but
it's borne out in the numbers of forty
percent carbon in the oak raisin
and what we're calling the a rise in the
sort of a temporary name right now until
we kind of do some mineralogy this is it
should be a or okras classifies mineral
or organic raisin remember some of the
chemical characteristics let's see the
Oh horizon has pretty high base
saturation and a is pretty high as well
but the oh and the E quite low which you
can also kind of see verified by the
high amounts of aluminum and iron and
the E and the B horizons we also have a
relatively high amount of manganese and
compared to others which it's also could
be of interest metal so putting the
nitrogen deposition for the site and
spread into perspective you can see here
in 2000 total deposition was a lot
higher than it is now
so so elevated above pre-industrial
presumed pre-industrial levels but it is
deposition is moving in the right
direction and you can see for nitrate in
particular makes up a pretty good
proportion of yeah so as for the
experiments themselves I took these
fools separated them and raisins and
made them into slurry miniature so I had
1 to 8 oil to solution ratio I put the
dish in different conditions I bubbled
in oxygen or nitrogen or these
experiments that are actually yet to
come and gotten all the results so I
wanted to chase well so I expected my
nitrogen 15 label and I wanted to trace
them through time so kind of on the
order of one one month's time
so I periodically took samples and son
treats them down to separate out this
soil and solution portions and I also
did the same with the control that did
not have any they will make since I am
interested in the partitioning into the
specific pools whole you know whole
range of analytes on solution amma
solids to both for total quantities as
well as for isotopic enrichment so s
topic enrichment and the soil solids as
well
and microbial biomass
so as I mentioned earlier you kind of
see the region in which nitrate is
active is really prominently in the
sebacic conditions so we really didn't
want to go into an toxic because then we
wouldn't really have much would be a
much harder to chase it any kind of we
would expect it tomorrow less disappear
immediately we didn't we wanted to kind
of drag it out a little bit so some of
the chemical species that are active in
these regions as I mentioned before you
know monitoring metals as well as these
different forms of nitrogen so where any
mentioned that electronics this is where
that comes in so I wanted to measure I
wanted to measure my redox status with
an or P Pro so oxidation reduction
potential Pro as well as monitoring by
these chemical species but we didn't
have a meter that was capable of running
six probes at once and I tried to like
use all the ones meters that we had in
lab Oh basically take them all of them
take up too much space so I did some
thinking and I realized that I could
make my own meter and so I did so I used
an Arduino as well as some arts from
Atlas scientific here so some of my own
meter combination data logger so rub the
code for these things and was able to
get some some nice time-resolved data
but I didn't have to you know go in
three times a day and manually write it
down whose more resolution
as I mentioned with this handy-dandy
little meter I monitored her Redux
potential and pH during the first three
days of incubation the reason it was
only the first three days was partially
I didn't want to contaminate my probes
with nitrogen 15 potentially excuse my
future results so I was also where the
use of chemical indicators comes in as a
way to monitor for Redux status after a
pool of probes just a brief overview of
the methods I did for this whole suite
of analytes color metric agents module
auto analyzer for salt organic carbon
mention Tomic absorption for total
manganese and solution for form
extractions for IMS and combustion
metals bed for total carbon oxygen and
then the nitrogen 15 tracer submitted
samples from police different potential
nitrogen pools to coil micro diffusion
was particularly fun any of you have run
that method but it is particularly
tedious and time-consuming so moving
into the results next few slides I'm
going to show or kind of for the total
analytes in solution on all of them I
have studded lines indicating my
detection limits for the various
analytes and blue arrows indicating when
the spike was added in this slide the
yellow yellow diamonds also indicate the
quantity of my tray added so you can see
the amount of spike that we added was
calibrated to try to get quantifiable
increase in enrichment but not so much
that we really change the native
nitrogen dynamic so we didn't want to
add 5 ppm so I can see this there seems
to be a little bit of total nitrate
concentration change but it's not crazy
and again everything I'm showing you now
is for the opposite conditions so we
really didn't see any nitrate at any
given time not surprising would expect
that more in the suboxone conditions the
authorized only one where we really saw
nitrate the other Fry's means the
nitrate more or less remains steady
throughout the experiment we did see a
lot of ammonium evolve during the course
of the 30 days and so here I'm showing
ammonium and so ammonium and purple and
total nitrogen and green we expected to
see a larger difference here usually
there's a lot more organic organic
nitrogen evolved so we're kind of we're
investigating right now why we're not
saying that potentially in over/under
estimation from analyses possibly real
but it would be surprising if it was
entirely absent in say the horizon so
again we see an increase in dissolved
organic carbon as well also kind of
expected with you expect that with
microbial processes as well as well as
release you
he leaves him more labile my carbon and
nitrogen metals remain pretty stable
again we don't really expect to see too
much the solution of metals under the
Aqsa conditions we the only one that was
like particularly surprising was this
increase and playable manganese here in
the B phrasing it might help explain one
of the results will show a mixed but
I'll come back to that in a minute
so now kind of the meat of the project
where does Italy will go so we found
that it does primarily go in that we do
get a lot more incorporation to the
solids in the high organic matter
horizons so highest with highest organic
matter o mixed with still high organic
matter a the e horizon was a little
surprising in that it was lower than the
B and also was the only one that didn't
seem to have reached kind of stability
in the same time frame the others look
more or less leveled off by day 15 but
raisin was slow going
so be interesting to see like you know
if we continued it to 60 days what level
of may have stabilized set here again so
purple is the soil nitrogen recovery
that I showed in this plot here
and you can see like one of the bigger
takeaways is that you can see in the e
and beef raisins a lot of this nitrogen
is still so the B horizon is kind of
interesting and they had the lowest week
total recovery of all of them which
going back to that manganese might be an
indication that we had more reducing
conditions than we thought we did
forgotten about Mike remove Imus so the
the measurements for the microbial
biomass were a little difficult and we
got a lot worse than we had expected
which makes quantifying the amount of
nitrogen tracer recovered in there but a
lot more difficult but from the
calculations we have then it seems to be
a pretty small proportion of it for any
given time so moving back to the
hypotheses movies we weren't able to
address at all
at this point because we hadn't done the
suboxone conditions you know those will
be continued throughout the summer but
we did find for Aqsa conditions soil
organic ice or organic matter big
correspond with more nitrogen partitions
and again we weren't really able to dive
too deep and to microbial processing or
so we would have to have to improve our
techniques
we see we also did find that all
horizons did have stabilization and
solids and bail did have some release of
ammonium again um problematic and we
also did indeed find that Lois Royal
organic horizons had more on the process
nitrate so kind of trying to take it
back to my original questions of X and
redox effects again not too much we can
do with redox effects at this point but
we do clearly see that horizon soil
organic matter has a very strong effects
and again until we get into the sub box
Vic it's kind of hard to say what effect
the iron and manganese minerals might
have because we really don't see a lot
of activity with that I'd like to thank
many people who have helped me along the
way mates
past and present who oops
who braved the wild takes an unexpected
rainstorm
[Applause]
yeah I haven't seen any follow that up
by asking you have an idea about where
that manganese is coming from why is it
so I or is that mine yeah I don't really
know if it's I in a broader sense in the
Smokies table I showed you manganese in
the B phrasing was a lot lower than say
I don't
I should actually look into what these
levels of manganese are in relation to
other soils I find it interesting that
the levels were actually I mean maybe I
was reading this wrong but they seemed
like they were higher than iron yeah
which is really surprising you know
people talk about iron reduction in soil
like and swells a lot but I'm not sure
how much that is because it's so much
more visible and in higher present in
the soils in higher quantities that
maybe these mostly gets overlooked
yeah I don't know how how frequently
people measure it dissolve manganese
will oxidize I mean just by looking at
the oxidized form that's where the color
is like people talk about it that way
but if you're talking about the reduced
form there's not a lot of reading to
visually you can't identify read these
magazines and you can with reduced iron
so I'm but again I don't know what that
ratio is iron I mean the reason why iron
is talked a lot about it other than
that's visual is that it is ubiquitous
and in quantities that are very much
higher than manganese the terrestrial
system in general so it's interesting
that you found that there but it's
relates to the respiration factor could
anything still be related to them to
fires because I was thinking a surface
layer you mentioned there were two major
fires I know there was some time ago but
if there's any mineral matter that was
up in the trees I need to ash and he the
ash will still be in that overrides
unless it's run often not really up I
run on spot under if they're what you do
seem to be horizon in the over eyes
running if somebody's fertilizer
supplemented by the fact that I don't
know I didn't realize about those how
severe those fires were I don't know
yeah I think they're pretty major we
have actually fires so we get some
fairly large portions so I don't I'm not
a chemist but you know our soil health
work manganese II came up many times as
as an important indicator which
surprised us in and then somebody
pointed out to me that that the redox
reactions are also very instrumental in
the decomposition of organic matter
that's not only the
the relative availability of oxygen but
it's also process itself of
decomposition doesn't make any sense but
I can say to your paper you probably
understand this a lot better but that's
somebody pointed it out to me that
that's one of the reasons why manganese
a 2 plus is then often more available
does it make sense yes that s part of
the decomposition process that there is
a reduction where you go to prison 42 is
one introduction that's it so that it's
a reduction I'll say to the paper but
but it does explain that you have much
higher levels in the upper prizes what
is worth are you gonna publish your
methods anyway there's joke as well
journalist did you oh we have to take
pictures and there's a general to
dedicated for methods called Joe
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu